[Music]
here's a quick message from
sidk today I've been able to donate to
the sick kids foundation and the sick
kids Trust these are two Charities one
that works here in the UK and one that
works in Canada and the United States
that deliver presents to children in
hospital at Christmas no child should go
without a Christmas present and I am
completely honored and makes me feel all
warm and cuddly inside to be able to
give a little bit of money to both of
these Charities this money is all of the
money that was earned up till today by
sidre all of the money from patreon you
know you can go to
patreon.com and become a member all of
the money from our members and all of
the YouTube um advertising money this is
meant that I've been able to give nearly
£1,000 today to charity for kids that
will basically now get a present at
Christmas and that's not thanks to me
that's thanks to you guys that's thanks
for you site trackers you are all
absolute Legends and look you can watch
Sidetrack and you can be entertained
damn it but also you can actually do
something that's good because we as a
community have given now more than
£4,000 to charity in the last two and a
half years to loads of different really
good causes we always try to listen to
you guys as well and if there is
anything that you think is important
that deserves that little bit of support
we're always up for doing it
so Sidetrack thank you so so much for
giving me the opportunity to be able to
do something so amazing I absolutely
love it and I absolutely love you guys
Merry Christmas Happy Holidays happy New
Year however you celebrate the love in
this world I'm hoping you're going to be
doing it this winter and I'm just hoping
that a few kids around the world are
going to get a present thanks to you
which is pretty cool thank you so
[Music]
much